just got back to the US have been out of
the country for roughly a year and in
that time I went to Iran for three weeks
and I was in a conversation the other
day and I mentioned that I said I went
to a rod and this guy was like are you
[ __ ] crazy they didn't kill you there
how did why the hell would you ever do
anything like that
and I said why do you say that and he
said well you know they chant death to
America they burn our flags they hate us
it's full of terrorism full of
terrorists I said okay they don't hate
us but what's with the flag burning okay
and that's what I want to go into here
and the death to America rant because
it's super offensive right and Americans
are very close to their flag there are
countries that are very close to their
flag Vietnam Turkey when Americans have
been taught from day one that the flag
in a way is is sort of like the Quran
for a devout Islamic person it is very
personal it's very special it's part of
the identity and this guy's going a
little over the top here as you can see
he's got a little flag on his
real-estate sign a little mini flag flag
on his house people put their flags
everywhere and for many Americans it's
depending on the person it's it's part
of their identity sobering this is very
very offensive and looked at as like a
direct assault or attack on on them in
their country
but I learned a lot in Iran I learned
why there are these death to America
marches and the burning of the flags so
here are the people doing it I want to
go over the people doing it first
there are basically three groups there
are a few more groups but the main
groups are government workers so these
are people working in banks insurance
companies teachers it's part of the job
you got to go you got to go show up at
these rallies another group is people
that honestly are against America and
these people it's more of a political
thing there are men against American
policy but they're all about standing up
and saying we are on ian's and America
is the enemy and thirdly you have people
that are showing up for the freebies you
know like the free food maybe a little
money
it's an event right so one of the big
differences between Iranians and I'd say
Westerners in general is they really
understand the difference between
politics and people much better than
Westerners so this down with America is
not down with the American people it's
not a direct assault or aggressive
measure against people it's actually
against policy and this isn't gonna be a
history lesson here but I strongly
suggest going through say even the last
hundred years of us-iranian relations
and look to be fair the Iranians have
gotten the short end of the stick for
sure now Americans had their hostage we
had our hostages for 444 days in Tehran
there was the Embassy bombing in Beirut
that the Iranians are believed to be
behind 17 US military men died but it's
also gone the other way it's gone the
other way there's over 200 people shot
down in the civilian plane in Iranian
airspace
by American forces there is the
iran-iraq war and Americans giving
Saddam chemical weapons to use against
the Iranians so imagine that for a
second imagine if the US and Canada were
at war and the Iranians were giving
Canadians chemical weapons to use
against the Americans how Americans
would feel about the Iranians right
that's like very invasive right more
invasive than a flag burning I would say
but the history goes very deep and I'm
not a fan of either government by any
stretch but the reason I'm making this
video is to show hey we have this what
the news media and what our politicians
are showing is not actually how the
people feel so Iran believe it or not no
joke is the most pro-american country
I've been to on this planet than a
roughly 90 countries and the people are
very warm and hospitable and I didn't
hear any down with America vibe against
me and I had a unique perspective
because I went in on my Italian passport
because Americans can't travel freely
there they have to be on a government
tour so I went on my Italian passport
and so I had a completely wide open trip
and Iran and my goal was to capture the
essence of the country capture that
people capture the feel and boy I did it
was one of the coolest experiences of my
life and I had nothing but warm
reception and hospitality so back to the
flag burning mmm the vast majority of
Iranians do not burn American flags it's
a very very small minority and it's
mostly a political statement Americans
look at our flag as
part of who we are or on Ian's look at
the flag as a political symbol so
there's different interpretations of
what a flag is routine the countries
currently Iran is getting heavily
squeezed by US policy with these
sanctions and these sanctions don't hurt
the people at the top these sanctions
don't hit her we were wealthy these
sanctions crippled the average person
and so food costs have doubled in the
last year people are losing their jobs
people can't afford the cancer medicine
for their families this is a direct
effect on the actual people and I'd like
to see two Americans imagine if a
commodity like gasoline was doubled
overnight and all of a sudden you had to
go to the pumps and pay $7 a gallon is
because of sanctions from Iran you'd be
pretty pissed off I mean that's just a
natural human response I'm actually
surprised the Iranians aren't more
pissed off when I was there there was
zero animosity like I said and what I
said I was Italian it was cool it was
like awesome and when I said I was
American it was over the top it may be
because it's more of a novelty not many
Americans travel there the end of the
day the news media loves this [ __ ]
the politicians guys like John Bolton
who want to go to war
love it more Errani ins will know who
John Bolton is than Americans because
his actions his words will directly
affect their lives more so
the burning of the American flag death
to America the overwhelming majority of
our audience
don't burn American flags don't shout
death to America are actually
surprisingly very pro-american and it's
an amazing fascinating place at the end
of the day us people all of us Americans
or audience we get along we're cool with
each other and Americans that don't
believe me right now I made videos of
Iran completely spontaneous completely
unfiltered I have everything from my
camera getting stolen to the most warm
receptions I've felt on the planet and
check it out go in with an open mind
with this stuff read into the history
but know that you're being fools you're
being manipulated by being told that
Iranians hate Americans it's just not
the truth at all
you